foreign
[Music]
trip this is gonna be iconic
you do understand this is a work shirt
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right look at me look at me look
at me now I love a grand Adventure I
heard that if you keep up with Chinese
businessmen they respect you more
listen up listen up listen up
you got a plug are you gonna play is it
a condom you look like you've had a lot
of things in your [__] I'm not a lot
of things just one thing but maybe
different varieties of that one thing
look at me look at me go stick your hand
up there like a claw machine trying to
get the stuffed bear
yeah
if you do not know where you come from
how do you know who you are I'm just a
garbage American who only speaks English
and a little Golem
en yeah
do you guys have that here yeah we have
it's all over the world y'all calling me
crazy let's just be adults are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises oh
you don't like Boba and you never [__]
an Asian guy damn still when I
masturbate I sometimes fantasize about
Splinter he's Asian he's a rat he's a
good father
laughs
[Music]